[Music]
okay good morning everyone
welcome to my talk about genetics my
name is Robin this omits we were talking
about evolving regular expression
features for text classification with
genetic programming
hi I'm Alma I'm a data scientist at ing
Jose bringing advanced analytics so at
ing we have a text classification
problem in this problem we want to
understand if a transaction name belongs
to a company or a private individual so
for this we have a very basic model is
this basic bag of words so we have some
vocabulary features which are not
working okay maybe I have to keep it
closed and in this one we have some very
basic features like basically what we're
holding transportation mr. John in that
case John most problem means it is a
private individual but it doesn't
generalize so well because let's say if
you have the example of John BV or John
and me does it look like a private
individual actually it is its most
preferred company therefore in order is
better we also have some reg X features
so in that case we can also consider the
space without space so anything that
ends with two letters and dots then our
question is can we automate this process
or maybe can we find even better regular
expressions than handcrafted reg X
features then at that point Robin joined
us for his master thesis so what have we
actually made we made essentially an
end-to-end text classifier we made a
genetic algorithm that gives us regular
expressions then we can use these
regular expressions to get matches on
pieces of text we can transform these
matches into features that can then be
used in a classifier so for example at
the bottom we have a piece of text and
we have two regular expressions given by
the genetic algorithm then we see that
it matches two
strings of digits and to transform it
into features we simply say did you find
a match or not if you did you get a 1 if
you didn't you get a 0 so here we have a
binary feature vector of 2 which we feed
to a classifier and which will then give
us a prediction which is in this case 1
so what was this actually an example of
this was an example of spam detection we
took a public data set from Cagle for
SMS messages which have both legitimate
and spare messages and we assume that
there is a difference between these
messages but we don't know what this
difference is so we want the algorithm
to automatically find patterns that help
predict whether something is a spam
message or a ham message so this is the
overview of the algorithm we start by
providing text to the Genetic
Programming algorithm which will then
work its magic for a while and give us
regular expressions we then use the
regular expressions to match on text get
match features which we can then use to
train a classifier and finally use the
classifier to make predictions so
internally the GP algorithm kind of
follows the same steps to determine what
is actually a good reg X so it proposes
a reg X then gets the feature on text
train the classifier and then evaluates
the classifier to determine a score
which indicates how well this regular
expression works so this actually
requires you to split the data set
multiple times because you need both
training data for the classifier but
then you also need to evaluate the
classifier so you have a second type of
training data to determine the
validation score so in essence the
classifier tries to optimize on its own
training data but then the regular
expressions are chosen based on the
validation data so they try to optimize
on that data set and then of course once
you have your final reg X you want to
evaluate that one so you also have a
test data set
so this is the overview of the Genetic
Programming algorithm this is how it
actually generates regular expressions
Genetic Programming is a type of
evolutionary algorithm so it's kind of
based on evolution in nature where you
start with a population of individuals
and offspring is generated from these
individuals so offspring is similar to
but still different from their parents
and then once you have the offspring you
do survivor selection so you look at
both the population and the offspring
and you keep only the best this goes on
in a loop for a certain amount of
generation so that the survivors become
the population in the next generation
this goes on in a loop for a certain
amount of generations and then after
that set amount of add generations you
return the best individual so an
individual gives us a set of regular
expressions an individual has a
phenotype and a genotype with the
genotype determining the phenotype and
the phenotype actually being the regular
expressions the the genes are given by a
tree with a node in the tree
representing a character in the regular
expression we introduce a special split
character the two pipes that enable one
individual to describe multiple separate
drag axis in a single tree and we use
the quotation marks as leave notes to
indicate that apart paths down the tree
ends so to create offspring we can do
crossover or mutation these are two
different methods once when you want to
make a new individual there's a random
probability of choosing either crossover
or mutation and we also implemented
multiple types of mutation that enable
offspring to either key
or drop parts of the parents tree then
once a individual is generated we also
immediately evaluate it using training a
classifier and evaluating it and since
you want a good classification
performance the the fit the higher the
performance the fitter we name the red X
so this is an example of crossover we
have two parents with their own trees we
select a random note in each of the
trees as a crossover point and what you
basically do is swap the the subtrees
from those crossover points to create
two new individuals so you can see we
have a / D and a / W as crossover points
and in the child's the the two nodes
have been swapped for mutation it's kind
of similar but still difference you have
only one parents and you still select a
random mutation point but now you
replace it with a random subtree and we
actually like I said we implemented
multiple types so in this example we
replace the ads with the random subtree
but you can also see that the B note in
the parent is lost we also implemented
the type called insertion where the B
would actually become part of the random
subtree so it's more like you're
inserting a part into the red X yeah
here are the results of the algorithm so
as you see there are some algorithm
finds to regular expressions in the
indus pam data and freedom if you have
websites in it then it is most probable
spend an algorithm caches with WW and if
there are codes or long pages like
numbers that algorithm caches with the
red X you see digit digit digit word and
this is for example especially this one
is not very easy to catch with regular
character engrams also something
because you need to generate two digits
and here you also see the performance
it's it has 85% f1 score and then on top
of it so this was the base of dollar
algorithm and then on top of it we also
did some upgrades so in a genetic
algorithm the complexity is usually a
number of generations time population
size because the main operation is
Fitness calculation and this main
operations Fitness collocation and in
our case we trained a model for for
every fitness calculation then it is
also linear to number of rows you have
because most of the classifiers are
almost linear the number of rows you
have then complex it becomes number of
generations time population service
times number of rows and we can paralyze
it we can split the data to K islands
and we can also split the individuals to
K Islands then in that case we get a
quadratic speed improvement because we
speed both of them at the same time you
can think of this splitting data as as
subsampling or then you and the
individuals actually it is very generic
procedure in genetic algorithms this
island idea and because it also gives
you the diversity premature convergence
is very common in genetic algorithms so
you may get a population which is very
conservative like it it's get stuck in a
local optimum then it can never
commercially a better optimum from that
and if you if since we migrated
individuals between the islands and we
also shuffle the data after and and
generations we can avoid this problem
and we also get like if you have 10
cores then you get 100 times more speed
improvement another thing we did on top
of off on top of the current algorithm
stacking because you want your reg X to
learn genetic brigades to learn actually
something different than
you can learn it worth grams or
character grams or another model and you
also don't want to base your time on
basic features you don't want you're
ready to learn just the future holding
like as a word because you can get them
much easier for this you you we follow
simple stacking architecture so we
create Auto fault predictions so it is
very critical that they're out of fault
and within cross-validation scheme here
cross-validation is actually not for
validation purposes but for training and
prediction purposes and then use using
these auto fault predictions as feature
then we can create regular expressions
which are different than you can
generate from word grams or some other
features and other thing you can also
have something like let's say a lefty
emit word I'm adding so in that case you
don't want to retrain this cost
algorithm over and over again therefore
you can go for just using auto fault
predictions and here are the results so
we we did it on top of character three
grams so for example previously we were
catching websites with regular
expressions now we don't need to because
we have character engrams
so www is casual and then we get some
new regular expressions which are really
difficult to get with other traditional
metal so this one means it is not worth
boundary at the end so when you get
punctuation at the end it is likely that
it is not spam but if there's no
punctuation then it's likely that it is
spam and we had this method we also
improve the f1 score so 90 percent from
85 percent yeah thank you
questions
you
[Applause]